chartres aux habits de lumière chaque
soir et la cathédrale le monument majeur
de la ville sort nord et de couleurs la
reine de la nuit a sans doute les
meilleurs scénographie de chartres en
lumières technique de vidéo de pointe et
renouvellement des thématiques la ville
n'hésitent pas à investir pas loin d'un
million d'euros chacun pour cet
événement
puis on a surtout géré cette exigence de
qualité c'est à dire qu'à aucun moment
on veut faire quelque chose qui soit
incompris on va faire quelque chose qui
soit pour le grand public c'est gratuit
donc ça c'est important aussi de le
rappeler et il est toujours si vous
voulez pour nous l'action majeure s'est
valorisé de magnifier ce patrimoine
pendant la chance d'avoir à chartres et
surtout de permettre aux gens de
redécouvrir ou découvrir la ville et si
toutes ces merveilles sont possibles
c'est grâce à ces trois techniciens nous
voici dans l'école gérard philipe où
sont installés les projecteurs ils
doivent tenir 183 nuit ici on a nos
trois vidéoprojecteurs donc voilà qui
sont là qui sont des vidéoprojecteurs
30-30 1000 lumens chacun donc c'est des
langues de 6000 watts à l'intérieur
toutes ces machines sont automatisées
géré par de l'informatique
un site comme le portail royal c'est
travailler au pixel près c'est à dire
que la société spectaculaire train
travail de manière très très précise et
du coup chaque pixel peut être quasiment
contrôlé sur la façade de la cathédrale
les techniciens se partagent les 23
monuments qu'ils contrôlent tous les
soirs pour réajuster les projecteurs et
réparer les pannes et en septembre la
ville de chartres va présenter des
nouvelles animations durant la fête de
la lumière